tous bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
sur france24 bienvenue dans journal les
français ont-ils pris trop tôt leurs
désirs pour une réalité c'est ce que
laisse à penser en tout cas ce matin les
russes qui réagissent à l'annoncé de
l'elysée l'année dernière l'entourage
des manuels macron se féliciter d'avoir
convaincu joe biden et vladimir poutine
de se rencontrer à l'occasion d'un
sommet ce qui serait loin d'être le cas
en croire ces dernières réactions du
kremlin on va retrouver tout de suite
notre correspondante en russie elena
volochine hélèna bonjour le kremlin qui
a donc réagi et qui indique qu'il n'y a
pour le moment aucun projet concret de
rencontre vladimir poutine et emmanuel
macron ont convenu effectivement de
poursuivre le dialogue mais via
seulement leur ministère des affaires
étrangères et leurs conseillers
diplomatiques c'est ce qu'indique un ce
dernier communiqué que faut-il
comprendre derrière ces propos derrière
ces mots
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
vladimir poutine veut absolument
maintenir le bras de fer il
effectivement il y avait ce communiqué
de l'elysée qui disait que vladimir
poutine serait tombé d'accord avec une
rencontre de joe biden est donc à moscou
on se demandait pourquoi il n'y avait
rien du côté du kremlin et c'est parce
que vladimir poutine ne veux pas aller
trop vite pourquoi parce que c'est trois
principales revendications vis-à-vis des
etats-unis et de l'otan n'ont pas été
entendus et le communiqué du kremlin qui
lui fait état de pertes mans discussion
téléphonique d'hier avec le président
français manuel macron ce communiqué il
dit que vladimir poutine que le kremlin
veut être entendu sur ces trois points
ils sont irrecevables c'est que les
occidentaux il s'agirait de nevers le
temps de revenir de faire revenir l'otan
en europe à ses positions de 1997 est à
dire retirer les troupes de l'alliance
de 13 pays européens
et là-dessus bladimir poutine pour le
moment semble intransigeant
même s'il semble prêt au dialogue parce
que s'il ne confirme pas une possible
rencontre avec joe biden dans tous les
cas elle s'est entretenue hier deux fois
avec le président macron le deuxième
coup de fil a eu lieu à une heure du
matin heure de moscou donc il y a le
signe que vladimir poutine veut
dialoguer mais on ne sait pas encore
s'il est prêt à aller au compromis elena
la chine voilà